thank you xander
that was quite an impressive talk
especially since you're just beginning
so now i want to welcome xander who's
joining us virtually
to ask some questions xander
thank you so much for having me this is
great
i am so impressed about how much you've
already learned when you say you're just
starting
it will be amazing what you can do once
you begin to actually
dive into this and do some real research
but already
there was tons of stuff that was new to
me
one of the things that i was really
curious
is um did you find
anyone else asking this question are you
i'm
like it seems now in retrospect almost
an
obvious question to ask but um
was has there been very much other
research like this or anyone else going
around
asking this question that's a really
good question i mean
the reason you know i started on this
project was really because
um you know we needed to solve this in a
way for ourselves we're the first use
case
and i thought that there was going to be
books in a body of knowledge
and you know experts that we could go
call um
for the longhow foundation to figure
this question out it was just like it
was amazingly blank
um it was so it was a really wide open
space i was like all right well i guess
now this is now our research project and
and um it seemed reasonable place for us
to do it uh
the um there there is there's been so
the resources are very scarce there was
a really interesting uh
author collective called the dark angels
collective that's that wrote a book
called um established
and it's stories of at least 12 of some
of the oldest
companies in the world uh and there's
certainly these lists that i've been
con concatenating um of both you know
organizations
um and companies that um
to kind of figure out which ones are
there but um but it's it's very
interesting when you have to
then contact them and the and the even
the modern the
modern management of a lot of these
organizations and companies they don't
have a lot of introspection around
how that's worked um they're very
focused on the now which is you know as
relative
also starting this project at the
beginning of the pandemic so they were
extremely focused on the now um at that
moment but it's uh
it's been interesting how how not
necessarily introspective
they all are that that was one of the
things i was wondering as you were
speaking was
were most of these institutions
organizations even aware
of their special age
and if they were
did they have any theories themselves
about
why they were long-lived well i
i think it varies a lot and i you know i
don't want to generalize too broadly
especially
after you know not talking to tons of
them but you know anecdotally
from the beginning of this certainly you
know they all kind of
really old organizations are often you
know they kind of brag about how old
they are
um and that's part of their kind of
story but the
um and their internal you know
organizational mythos
but um i find it interesting how like
when i one of the things questions i
came back to people was like how did you
survive the last pandemic it was only
100 years ago
which in all you know many of these
companies are over a thousand years old
or
organizations and they're like oh that's
a really good question i have no idea
and uh you know even for something that
they were in the middle of trying to
figure out how to re-survive
um they had not asked that question uh
and so um it's uh it's interesting one
of the
one of the funders of this project was
james uh anderson of bayley gifford
uh and and he had already looked at for
instance
the way he had he found that out was
looking at the public
uh the public reports the kind of annual
reports of the company
um around that time and it's just what
he said it was wild when when
people were um that those reports
you know as the pandemic was unfolding
they
they kind of they don't even mention it
in these in these reports until it's
like really a bad problem it's kind of
very similar to the beginnings
of of this one so it was interesting
that that it was very similar problems
that were being repeated very
very in real time and again to your
first approximation on this very initial
look at it um do you did you find it
that there were other advantages to this
kind of
long liveness besides survival i mean
other than the fact that they were
surviving were there anything else about
them were they
surviving at a better profit rate or was
it
um you know their metabolism different
or were there anything else
about them that you could kind of detect
that might be
a possible theory well there seems to
very much be an internal
culture thing
where the the kind of employees are
prepared
mentally for this and this management is
mentally for this where um you know i
think we saw this for
instance play out the in the opposite
way at the beginning of the last
you know big.com crash where the the
employees were in no way and the
management was in no way prepared
to shrink their company by even 20 much
less
60 percent you know you saw and they
weren't ready to reinvent themselves so
you know we saw
you know the music industry and during
the time of of music becoming
a digital commodity that and a
subscription service
that you know but there's you could talk
to people within the music
companies themselves and every single
one of them knew that
their model was not going to survive
what it was but they could not kind of
they couldn't they didn't culturally
have the internal story to fix that
they they you know they sold music on
plastic circles that's what they did
and it took apple and you know
eventually you know other things like
napster forces to basically just take
that away from them
um and and so um it's it's it's very
important it seems to
have developed a company or
organizational culture
that you you know you prepare people and
and um and it was
jeff bezos who who told me you know
about talking about amazon's who said
you know as the stock price was doubling
i told everyone that you know they
weren't twice as smart as they were last
quarter
and when the stock price goes down
you're not twice as dumb as the last
quarter
we're just you know we have to keep
making the company that that
that uh that has a real business model
and we just keep doing the thing and so
i think that
engendering that is is seems to be one
of the most important things
yeah so i i want to um
bring in another a questionnaire um i'm
going to introduce um
nick bryce um bryce sowitz who
is the um director of development for
long now
and um nick you have some questions
yeah thanks so much kevin and xander
this was a fantastic talk i've been
looking forward to this for a while
um because it's such relevant research
to so many different institutions you
had already mentioned
that uh james anderson with bailey
gifford had you know proudly supported
the work that you're working on
as has the ethereum foundation um and i
just think there's a broad
there's a broad application for the
kinds of ideas you're running into i'm
curious about this idea of
continuity as memory and then memory
kind of is something that's permanent
but i'm wondering if you've run into
situations where the continuity of an
organization or the continuity of
practice
has been served by a kind of selective
forgetting
if there are instances you run into
where people have decided what to leave
behind
because circumstances have changed or
because their goals have changed
um so have you run into anybody who's
deciding how do we decide what to
remember and what to forget
well i think it is really interesting um
that question of like how
and but i think it's maybe different
than you phrased the question at least
from what i've seen is that you
you don't want you don't want the the
people that are running your
organization
so hung up on the way things have been
done in the past that they can't welcome
in another generation
usefully that they can't listen to the
fact that there are new tools there are
new
markets there are new situations in the
world that that is
and that is possible for a company to
retry an idea they might have tried
100 years ago a thousand years ago um in
a new environment with new tools
and so if they can't do that i think
that's that's that's
almost as problematic as not having
those stories to tell
themselves so finding the way to
to be able to have at least it seems
about three generations within
an organization that's talking to itself
and each other in a productive way that
knows how to discern that you know you
don't want
you don't want a generation basically
saying oh you know if in even
even a current generation if there's if
if they have seen how
how they that organization or even other
organizations maybe have failed at
something over and over and over again
they might not try the new thing um and
so how do you
how do you temper that information in a
way that says all right well
maybe we're different now um and it's
worth trying so i think that
that seems to be an interesting question
of how best
any organization can listen to its
youngest members
to find some of the kind of new energy
of the world the new things that might
be happening in the world
the middle generation to interpret that
and the oldest generation to be giving
some of that wisdom
and and put those things together in a
way that
that doesn't hamper the organization but
also helps it answer those questions
going forward
that's a great idea the
multi-generationality of a continuous
organization is probably one of the
cooler
cooler aspects of getting people to kind
of pass the baton back and forth across
time
we were talking earlier about continuity
as memory but i'm also really interested
in this idea of continuity uh in an
aspirational sense
so there are certain things that you
know take a week for us to do and there
are certain things that might take a
century for people to do or two
centuries
and if you want to do something on a
time scale that you know
exceeds the human lifespan you're going
to need something like a long-lived
institution to coordinate people
across generations but as we all kind of
know
institutions can end up in a spot where
they're in the business of just staying
in business
um and but you know so if you were
setting out for something that was going
to take 250 years
have you run into organizations that
have baked into their culture or baked
into their governance structure
a way to adhere to the original idea of
this is going to take 250 years
and there's a wind-up procedure i'm
thinking about the examples you know
things like these breweries brasseries
hotels hot springs
um they kind of exist indefinitely but
then i think of things like cathedrals
and there has to be some kind of a
you know a limit to that organization if
you run into a
whole suite of organizations that have
kind of a finite ending point
you know i mean that's an interesting
question i mean i think um
you know there's certainly some types of
projects that that people assume to only
take a certain amount of time but
companies and organizations they kind of
think that they
are going to be around at least in you
know nobody wants to design a job
that they're going to be out of um and
so in some way many organizations and
companies
more than anything are actually just the
perpetual perpetuation machines
and because everybody in the org is very
interested in them perpetuating i think
certainly we've seen you know there was
um
very famously benjamin franklin um
created the benjamin franklin trust that
was supposed to
invest it was actually a reasonably
small amount of money at the time
and pay itself out i think over 200
years totally
or half at 100 years and a half at 200
years to both the cities of
philadelphia and uh and boston um and um
and then also famously it was they that
organization that managed that
then has now perpetuated the benjamin
franklin trust and has ignored those
original awards but
um certainly we've seen um you know
we've seen certain philanthropies that
were designed to be paid out
and and cancel themselves out and i
think when that's done within the living
space of the person who started it they
seem to actually do that
when it's left to go to another
generation again those those
organizations just become these self
perpetuation machines that um that
usually break that trust of the original
uh of the original donor so it's um i
think that's
of the examples that i know that have
really just been designed to cancel out
that's
and and go extinct on purpose that's one
of the only ones i know of
and and that's great and so so one of
the ways that those kinds of purposes
are passed forward in time
is through different generations talking
to each other and having a conversation
about what to remember and what to
forget
but we also have this ability to use
texts and to use records
across long periods of time to try and
understand what people from
past instances of an institution were
thinking or wanted or you know what
their intentions might have been like
and i understand that you actually have
had a chance to check out a number of
different archives you know because of
course long now is
involved in some very special archiving
projects but then specifically
um i'm thinking of a living organization
like the catholic church
um have you been able to talk to them
about how they maintain
a continuous thread going all the way
back through their history
um well i was uh very lucky enough to to
visit the vatican archives at one point
and the
um the the interesting so i don't have a
broad story from all levels of the
vatican but at least from the vatican
archives
um i thought it was really interesting i
mean the catholic church was famously
one of the oldest
con currently accident organizations on
the planet at about 2000 years almost
um and the the the thing that
um and the vatican artifices themselves
are amazing in their own right
but uh when i was getting the tour i
walked by this one room
that um that had all these really thin
drawers in it and there was all these
guys in
like these little white suits picking
things out of the drawers and it was
actually it was that vatican was in the
process of closing down for easter mass
which is a rare moment that that the
main basilica
is closed um and so all these guys were
picking out um
tiles uh for maintaining
the um the mosaics of the of saint
peter's basilica
and it turns out that over 500 years ago
when they commissioned the mosaics
they also commissioned the artist to do
overruns
and and famously the artists in the
records of that complained that they had
to do overruns of all these colored
tiles
they're like why do you know we'll we'll
just we'll just do it whenever you want
it and they're like no we want we want
them on hand and so
for over 500 years they've been able to
grab these tiles and
and repair and sure enough as we were
walking out of st peter's basilica
there was they had erected all these uh
scaffolds and were you know
replacing all of these tiles and the
mosaics not necessarily textual
um thing records but these kind of
physical records
that um that this organization had
thought
you know hundreds of years in in advance
to basically to solve what would be and
totally unsolvable problem it was a very
difficult to solve problem
um that it was very easy for them to in
a way ask for that at the beginning
as long as they had the continuity of
the organization to you know keep them
in the drawer
label the door properly and remember it
uh
you know 500 years in advance so that
was i think it was a great example of
that
so um thanks nick some great questions
and um we want to move now to
take some questions from the audience um
stuart brand is off to the side sorting
those questions on youtube or facebook
or any or
is in the video here if you have
questions one of the first ones he has
pertains to what nick was just saying
it's from
sci-fi action on youtube and the
question would be
in these long-term institutions are
there any that can
maintain innovation while they're trying
to
not just be a perpetual survival machine
but
are you aware of any that that
continue to innovate at the same time
um i think certainly you know i
mentioned one of the
examples i mentioned was universities i
think universities you know clearly
have at least whole parts of them that
are always innovating i think their you
know their
basic model and their basic need that
they're serving is education
uh but they you know the great research
universities of the world are
are totally innovating a lot um
i think that in the cases of probably
financial institutions is another place
where
you know the oldest financial
institutions have to stay at the
forefront
of financial products and i think maybe
some of the cases where some of the
oldest ones where they
you know they might have probably
survived some of these big uh financial
chucks
by at least tempering all right we're
going to get into structured
you know leveraged lending around real
estate and then uh
and then maybe had suffered a very bad
problem in 2008 but had enough of their
business
uh tempered to not have gone out of
business because of that
um and so i think there's there's always
a place where
you should be i think any organization
should be innovating i think
when you're talking about you know the
world's oldest hotels in japan
um or europe they probably don't have a
ton to innovate they're
in a way that actually by serving people
the same way for generations is really
what they're doing i'm sure they've
built a website at this point to the
lord
for a large can say but that's you know
they you know there's something about
advertising themselves maybe but they
you know in a way they're they're
advertising that they have not changed
for a long time
i think there's there's definitely a a
spectrum of that
their business is serving that which
doesn't change and so that's
part of the reason why they haven't
changed so um
stewart himself had had a good question
which was in this research
was there anything that surprised you
that maybe you were not expecting when
you set out
well i think i mean i mentioned it
towards the end which is this keeper of
the fabric role i think what was so
surprising was how
informal that role is in in so many
institutions and i brought up the ones
that
where it is formalized like in japan
temple building
or um or cathedrals but um i think
it's so funny where you're talking to
the ceo or or the
lead of an organization now and they're
like well you know it's actually this
guy who
doesn't even work for us but he comes in
and tells stories
um you know periodically at team you
know company-wide things
um that used he worked for us a long
time ago and so this
and it's and they all regard this person
with
very highly as an important person
within for their organization but that's
not even within their organization
um and it's not formalized and so i
think i think it's a very
interesting lesson for for any
organization like how
do you formalize this at least in a way
maybe you just give them an honorific
that they
they kind of feel the importance of of
that
um storytelling part and you know really
the oldest
thing the oldest thing we have for
conveying knowledge is storytelling
and so it's it's the thing that we know
can and will last for a very long time
but um how we tell those stories uh
within organizations i think is an
interesting question right
and it seems like most of what you've
seen so far has been kind of oral
transmission rather than
anybody kind of writing it down except
for maybe those stones in
japan so that oral tradition but maybe
what we're looking for is
a different mechanism besides an oral
transmission
yeah and i think the the other
interesting thing that i have found that
is kind of surprising is that the
when you go and you look up the the
official history of some of these
organizations
um because they all kind of you know on
their website or somehow you know
they're talking bragging about how long
they've been around they have this very
official history
that has that really is very bad at
telling
the the bad stories which are really the
stories that you need to understand
to have an organization last like i want
to know how that organization survived
the pandemic 100 years ago i want us to
know
how they survived the plague you know
600 years ago and these are
these are the stories i want to know and
they they basically they just gloss
right over it they're like well this is
you know
here's how we did all these things great
um and clearly those you know those were
problems for
for these organizations uh and and their
lessons are valuable that are they're
just they
they're either not documented even their
formal internal hit some company
some companies have informal internal
historians
but they you ask them that question like
oh well we'll go let's see if we can
look this up and
they they tend to not be well recorded
times i think mostly because
people are they're scrambling during
those times it's probably it's the most
difficult time to take time to make
records
um and when they're coming out of them
they're really thinking forward not
thinking backward
so i think it's an interesting question
in general of how we can be better at
this
and i think i mentioned the who the
world health organization
that you know they have collected and
cdc have collected amazing information
about the current
pandemic that we're in but how how is
that being preserved for
the next one that could be a hundred or
more years out i don't know
so um chris peel another um audience
member suggests a question of
wondering um whether there are things
like tax
incentives or other kinds of structures
that might be implemented by the
government
to encourage generally these kinds of
long-lived institutions and maybe
you have a 40-year investment that
is paying off in 100 years or
other means in which governments have
you seen at the government level any
kind of encouragement
anywhere in the world maybe even japan
where they
incentivize a long-lived institution
that's an interesting question i mean i
i to be honest i have not looked that
much at tax code um you know certainly
it seems that in in places like the
united states
that we tend to we tend to really deal
with
you know big problems more as an
insurance model that we
um we just kind of assume that we're
going to wait for the problems and we're
going to
solve it with insurance um in europe a
little bit different and you know
the you know holland famously you know
really is building
in infrastructure for literally ten
thousand year events around flooding
um where in the united states we just
kind of let the flood happen and then
hope that insurance companies uh will
will solve it um so there's
there's certainly that and we certainly
see some financial instruments like the
you know the 99-year
um agreements in in hong kong or panama
canal uh but it's and i think maybe the
only thing i could imagine in the tax
structure that i know of is is countries
that incentivize uh having children
and incentivize education but you know
the education the money that you might
spend on education and the united states
does this to some extent at least with
the education side
in europe much more around actually
having children
because as i mentioned the most of the
industrialized war
world is now below replacement value and
causing very interesting kind of
economic problems when there's no
children adding into the economy
um so um so i think that's the only
place i know of
offhand but it's a great research topic
um right
you could imagine a government saying if
your institution lives to be 100 you
taxes are half or something just like a
social security
level um so here here's another
interesting question from brewster kale
who started the internet archive
backup basically a long-term project if
there was one
he was saying well you know just as in
humans we often have certain diseases
associated with old age
are there any particular kind of attacks
or
or threats or challenges that
longer lives institutions might exhibit
or
um be susceptible to that younger ones
don't
that's a really interesting question i
mean i think that
often at least the little bit that i
know
maybe more anecdotally at this point um
then i i will hopefully later in this
project but the
um is this problem of of how
how the youngest generation can talk to
the oldest generation and vice versa so
how
how both wisdom can go down and and new
knowledge can go up
um seem to be where things fail um
if if the oldest if the old generation
that's running a company or the older
generation that's running a company
can't listen to the new market forces
can't listen to the new
things that are happening in the world
they're basically going to miss these
opportunities
and then the same thing can go the other
way if the if the generation can't
listen to
the old generation then um then they
they might not they might keep making
you know repeat a mistake that could be
fatal to
an organization so i think um i think
that's the that's probably the first
thing that i've i've found so far but
interesting question right yeah well i
mean but it's i think there's you know
there's always a case for forgetting on
some level you don't
if if the only thing you know is how
something has not worked
you may not ever try it again um and so
i think that's a
that's a that's a real problem that is
worth thinking about how you
temper that kind of information within
an organization so
one of the ones i was one of the things
i was wondering is if there was any kind
of
lateral communication between
longer-lived institutions whether any of
them were exchanging
or realizing again that they were part
of a community in any sense
of where they were sharing what they've
learned david
grossoff was wondering if
in the way that the dalai lama was
trying to
pass on transmitting information in the
diaspora whether there was
in other institutions some sense of well
we've lasted this long how have you done
it
and so is there is there any sense of
them even communicating with other
long-lived organizations
um surprisingly it seems very very
limited to my knowledge
and they um they often kind of very much
live within a bubble and i think they
have this kind of feeling of like all
right we've been around for
600 years like who do you know what do
we need to who do we need to really talk
to we're pretty much
you know outlast i mean one of the one
of the organizations i mentioned was the
you know the temple um complex at ise in
japan and
and i think was talking with their own
their historian
and apparently they they were approached
to become a unesco award world heritage
site and you know they're
over 1600 years old if at minimum and
and so you know their response was like
why do we care about this
you know 50 year old organization that
might tell us that we're important
you know once once unesco is 1600 years
like come back to us and
and and that maybe we'll listen so i
think it was uh it was
it was interesting um to hear that
there's there's one organization that i
know of that's it's
it's it's very um informal which is a
french it was french founded
of family run businesses that have
lasted
over 200 years uh around the world and
um and several organizations have or
several mostly companies family-run
companies
have are members of that and i'm
forgetting the name of it it's a french
name
um but um they do so they apparently
talk to each other and sometimes have
meetings or at least
get together um and and pay attention to
each other
so maybe this is a last question to to
wrap
up with but the law now foundation
itself is now 25 years
old we think of ourselves in our first
quarter a quarter being a quarter
century
um you've done this research
what have you come back to take back
from that
to change the way that you want to run
the long now foundation at this director
what is there a specific
lesson that you thought we really should
do here
this this this is something that that we
should be doing
um well i mean you actually mentioned it
i think the um
the the thing that has come out of this
research in a way it was inspired by
these temples that are rebuilt every 20
years in japan is this
you need to i think formalize a
refreshing cycle
where the generation that you know after
25 years that's roughly you know a human
generation in a way
is is says all right well what dna do we
want to bring with us
and what and how do we want that to
instruct the next
25 or 20 or you know whatever it is
whatever your cycle is
how do we want that to instruct but not
limit um and so we want it you know we
want that
that's what we're kind of doing right
now at long now at 25 years is
you know the founders had a you know
came from a time you know
started in the mid 90s it was very
optimistic technological time
um and you know it's certainly become a
less optimistic technological time now
um but how do we how do we take that dna
make it inspiring to another generation
but not over limit that problems because
you want new people to come in who
are interested in solving new problems
what is the next ten thousand year clock
project the next rosetta project
um that is going to be really
interesting as we finish some of these
other projects and that's that to me is
the big challenges
is not becoming too too limiting in the
information we hand off
but giving people enough framework that
they feel empowered to do
new and amazing things you often talk
about trusting the future
in in a certain sense and that seems
like part of what
you want to do with a long-lived
institution is in some ways
transmit that trust forward and that
faith in the next generation
indeed i think i mean trusting the
future i think that's a key kind of
both preserving optionality and trusting
for the future is something that has
has really emerged over the whole time
that we've been at long now is that
if you're making any decisions that that
limit the next generations
more than than open possibility for them
you're probably
not helping that generation like you
they are going to have more information
about their
their present than you could ever
predict about you know from as a
futurist
um so how can you how can you make
choices that don't take away their
optionality as is
seems to be a really important principle
and i know that you're
really waiting for the covid period to
pass
so you can get out and begin to visit do
you have
a specific approach or plan to
answer some of these questions and can
maybe the people in the audience
in some ways help is there some way that
anyone who's interested in this could
participate in this
certainly i mean i'm i'm always open to
look for um
to you know new interesting examples for
this um
and connections it seems it's in many
cases it's very difficult to kind of get
to the right person in some of these
organizations that will talk to you
about this
um and so i've been hiring researchers
in different countries to start making
kind of doing the research within those
countries and then hopefully starting to
make some of those connections that
um i can go and interview them because i
think i think i'm going to find
very interesting things when i visit
physically when i talk to these people
physically and
i i think i'm going to get again a lot
better information that i get from
official histories that you might get
you know reading a website or or
something like that i've already been
getting some good ideas
um you know to read things like um in
some cases
the the company reports from that time
that were officially the reports from a
time of great shock or change
um and um and kind of see how
the that company organization talked
about it but there's there seems to be
very spotty records around those times
so
i'm hoping if i go there i might get uh
be able to you know open a shoe box
that's been
at the bottom of someone's desk for a
long time and and pull out some letters
that might
shed a little bit more light into it
well well xander i wish you
and we all wish you the best of success
in your investigation and trying looking
at this systematically
i think it would be a great service to
the long now and our
interest in fostering long-term thinking
so thank you for this fantastic talk i
learned so much
which i had no idea about um we really
appreciate your
being here thank you so much well it was
you know it's obviously
it was great to be on the other side of
the chair for uh for one of these talks
and
uh thank you for hosting and um looking
forward to some of the future talks at
long that was fun to present here
and i thank uh members and other
um audience who are joining us for this
talk
of the thinking long term and we hope
that you can join us in another
seminar for long-term thinking thank you
you